hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom livestream which is something
that all of us at Khan Academy started
up once we started having mass school
physical closures I should say many
seems like a lifetime ago is just a way
to keep in touch have interesting
conversations and understand what's
happening in the world around us in
education and beyond before we get into
the conversation with a very exciting
guest today I always give the reminder
to folks that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and we
exist because of philanthropic donation
so if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating I want to
give a special shout out to several
corporate partners who stepped up
especially because of our kovat response
you could imagine our traffic is almost
three times what it typically is our
costs are going up we're trying to put
more programs out there sooner than
later and so special thanks to Bank of
America google.org and Novartis AT&T
fastly for stepping up and for the many
other supporters for Khan Academy over
the years we would not be able to do
what we're doing now if not for the many
years of support and we're still running
at a deficit and so whether you're a
corporate partner or even a small donor
who can give $3 $5 everything makes a
difference so that we can continue to
accelerate what we're offering with that
I'm really eager to to introduce our
guest Chancellor Richard Carranza as the
Chancellor of the New York City Public
Schools the largest school district in
America and obviously a school district
in a part of the country that has had
unusual challenges as we've gone through
this crisis Chancellor Carranza thanks
so much for joining so thank you so much
for the invitation I'm really honored to
be here and I want to say hi to
everybody I'm sure many of our students
are are watching as well because they
love what you do so thank you for the
invitation no no and so you know what
I'm fascinated by is I would love you
know what was going on in your life you
know you are a New Yorker and obviously
you are you you you you're the head of
the largest school district highly
complex School District in the country
what was going on in your head and what
was at the end of March when the it was
clear that we had a pandemic in United
States it started to become clear that
York was getting have hard-hit and
people were at least starting to surface
the notion of school closures what was
going on in your mind well we had been
preparing for that eventuality back end
of February and one of the things that's
pernicious about this this pandemic and
this virus is that it's it's it's had so
many iterations it keeps on iterating
and it looks different but we were
trying to be prepared so when the
decision was made on March 16th that we
would transition to remote learning the
one thing that we kept in mind was that
school was not closing we were gonna
continue learning but it was just not
going to be in a face-to-face
environment and that's why we said we've
been in remote learning mode ever since
then it's been just a matter of making
sure that our teachers and our students
and our families quite honestly because
caregivers parents guardians
grandmothers neighbors they've all kind
of become new teachers as well and
supports for their students so we're
making sure that the entire organization
is really pivoted to developing
resources providing resources and
supporting students and families in
remote learning and I want to remind
everyone if you have questions for
Chancellor Carranza or myself feel free
to post your questions on Facebook and
YouTube where this is streaming and we
have team members we're going to be able
to surface questions to us chancellor
Carranza you know you know and that lets
say that week or two before that March
16th when the schools closed you know
what what what was the what was the
order of operations you know there's so
many schools I think it's what 1.2
million students you have how how did
y'all think about internet access how
did you think about I know school
lunches special needs students what was
how did you juggle all of that so I I
have an incredible team of folks that I
work with that had already started doing
the logistical planning around those
issues but obviously we were very
concerned about if you remember during
that time period even the medical
professionals were learning new things
about how this virus was promulgating
itself in the community so we were
trying to stay up-to-date because school
was still in session and following the
advice
our medical experts we were we were very
much into protocols about if there's a
self-reported case if there's a
confirmed case what is the protocol we
shut down the school how do we notify
families but as we became more and more
apparent that we were going to go into
remote learning then the focus was
really about our most vulnerable
students students with disabilities are
multilingual learner students are
immigrant students students in temporary
housing which is a term that we use in
New York City for homeless students and
all of all of our vulnerable populations
at the same time we were also very
concerned about the fact that you know
New York City almost nine million
residents in New York City and it was
very clear that the emergency responders
are medical personnel are essential
workers really depend on the schools for
their students to be taken care of so we
at the same time as we were planning how
his transition to remote learning and
shut the physical buildings down we were
also standing up over a hundred and
fifty what we call regional enrichment
centers wreck sites all over the city of
New York and every borough specifically
for the children of first responders
medical personnel essential workers so
that they would have they could still
continue to serve the residents of New
York City and know that their children
would be taken care of that was a
surreal experience because now you have
children in a school environment so all
of the social distancing and the face
mask and the precaution and having 24/7
cleaning happening all the time and how
do you serve the food all of those were
the things that we were talking about
and planning for in addition we know
that eighty over eighty percent of the
students in New York City's public
school is qualified for free reduced
lunch so the poverty is real we know
that many of our students get their
meals at school so at the same time we
planned for and stood up over 450 meal
hubs across the city and every borough
where students could come get breakfast
lunch and dinner all in one fell swoop
and then of about three weeks ago we
extended that to not only children but
any resident can come to a meal hub and
get all three meals as well so we stood
that up as well because we know that
it's important for for students and
their their parents not to go hungry
I'll tell you this out right now since
we transition March 16th
we have served almost nine and a half
million meals out of those food hubs and
we're we're averaging right now a little
over half a million meals per day that
are being distributed and then we're
also doing other things we heard from
some of our students that said you know
during the school year we get feminine
hygiene products at our school for free
and you know there's a need for that so
we've started now distributing feminine
hygiene products that these meal hubs
again trying to be responsive to the
needs of our community and making sure
that they're being taken care of that's
that's incredible I can't even imagine
the complexity of doing all of that so
so quickly and we have a lot of comments
coming in you know one just from
Facebook David Wang says thanks for
taking care of the homeless and those
who don't speak English tl quo from
facebook says wreck sites fantastic idea
they're asking what it's like you kind
of described it already you know it
seems like it's a hard and I hadn't even
thought about that dimension of the
Christ angel you just talked about it
that yes you these health care workers
need some some type of support there's a
question here from from Leslie elder
grill from YouTube I work for the
Bagwell College of Education in
georgia's Kennesaw State University what
can educate or prep programs do to
support what you believe will be the new
norm Chancellor carranza I'll add a
question so there's a short term how did
you navigate that where you had to go to
whatever you want to call it remote
learning distance learning in fairly
short order
what were the expectations how did you
do training and then what do you think
is you know to Leslie's question what do
you think is going to be the the new
normal if there is one great question so
thank you for both of those questions so
let me get some context so when we
decided that we would close schools we
were fortunate that we had three days to
prepare for remote learning and and and
you know people are gonna say what do
you mean you had three days well in
essence we took a system of over 150,000
teachers 1.1 million students and in a
matter of three days 72 hours we
completely transition to remote learning
now we know that many of our teachers
were already experienced with and had
done work with virtual learning remote
learning and online learning blended
environments flipped classrooms really
incredible work here in New York City
but we also know that there was a
modicum of art of our teachers that had
never had that experience so it was a
crash course of boot camp if you will
those three days to make sure that
teachers had their devices you were to
log in we created something in our in
our department learning management
system called teach hub where we put
links the link to sell the con academies
in there and lots of resources for
teachers to teach remotely from home so
we we stood that up we did intensive
training for those three days and then
we went into remote learning mode and
the schools have been closed except for
the ones that are functioning for as
food hubs or these rec centers so for us
it was really making sure that the
educators had what they needed what was
also important was to recognize that not
all of our students had devices so
immediately for those three days schools
assigned the school-based laptops and
devices to their students again
prioritizing the most vulnerable
students first students that needed
those devices so students went home with
those devices are about 175,000 of those
devices but what we immediately did as
well is we worked with whoever could
actually produce for us and that
happened to be Apple so we put an order
for three hundred thousand Wi-Fi enabled
iPads and I'm happy to tell you and we
did a survey and we had principals and
teachers in contact with their students
they were giving us that information as
to who needed devices and remember these
are 1,800 schools in New York City so
lots of information flowing to us but
I'm happy to report that as
this week we've now delivered shipped
and delivered over 290 thousand devices
that are in the hands of our students
right now so short-term versus long-term
the short term is making sure that our
students had those devices making sure
our teachers have the support that they
needed to transition to remote learning
but the long term implications are vast
and profound and this gets to the
question that came in as well about
teaching programs a crisis is always an
opportunity to do something better and
we in education have lamented the
digital divide for decades this has
forced us across the country to really
take on the digital divide and if
there's any silver lining with this
pandemic is that when we get to the
other side of this pandemic we will have
bridge the digital divide in New York
City that's an amazing amazing
accomplishment but I think it's an
important accomplishment now what that
means is that teacher preparation
programs we're never going to go back to
the way it was so technology and being
able to find resources and utilize
resources in different ways the ability
using technology to personalize even
more so the learning needs of students
in a very individualized way we're
seeing that there's tremendous power
right now in the hands of teachers to be
able to do that so if I was a professor
in a teaching University preparing
teachers I would be insisting that we
have lots of pedagogy for this flipped
classroom online teaching virtual
teaching that teachers have the
wherewithal to be able to use Google
classroom or to be able to use a zoom or
to be able to use Microsoft teams or
WebEx because it'll provide them with
additional tools in their pedagogical
toolkit to be able to continue this
trend that students will be learning in
in virtual mode at least some segments
of their of their day and it provides us
with a lot of other opportunities I'll
give you just one more example sorry for
going on and on but I'll get over it
so when you think about the
that in AP classes advanced placement
classes mm-hmm in New York City excuse
me in New York City we with over 700
high schools we have some very small
high schools that may not have the
ability to have an AP teacher for let's
just say ap statistics so what we
piloted this year was a virtual remote
AP class a bunch of the AP classes and
the notion was that if we have a very
well-trained very capable ap teacher
let's say in statistics and they're at
their school doing their job and doing a
great job but we know there's five other
schools that have students that want a
1:1 student at one school to students at
another school three and another if we
could set up that virtual classroom with
that teacher providing AP instruction
and then those students remotely at
those other schools are able to tap into
that teacher and get their AP
instruction would it work while it was
working gangbusters before we went into
remote learning guess what that has
provided us now with the opportunity to
think about okay how do we leverage the
real skill set that we have embedded in
our teachers and provide those learning
opportunities to more and more students
especially in students and communities
that have been historically underserved
and especially in small schools where
you don't necessarily have a lot of
teachers but you you still have students
that want to have those experiences
those are the kinds of experiences that
I think have presented themselves to us
as a response to this crisis and I think
that we we have a responsibility not to
lose momentum once we get back to
in-person learning you know in-person
learning will look different and I love
that last example because it really
shows how there's an there's a maybe a
silver lining that now these teachers
are able to go beyond the confines of
their individual classrooms and it's
kind of like a the whole district is
serving the whole district which is
which is really really powerful you know
tons of questions and comments from
Facebook Shelly fact Shelley Fox says
thank you to the New York City IT device
deployment team actually relate to that
you know you're just kind of
nonchalantly said yeah we deployed two
hundred ninety thousand laptops and
we've essentially solved the digital
divide exactly how did
happen cuz we talk to a lot of districts
obviously deleverage Kahn Academy you
need device access on internet access I
am curious about the the broadband
aspect of it and then just how did you
pull that off you know there's other
superintendents who might listen to this
and they would love to be able to
emulate what you did so I want to get
tremendous kudos to our device
deployment office as well to our
purchasing and procurement office to to
our mayor so very early on when we knew
that this device issue was going to be
an issue we immediately jumped into
action mode and we contacted we put out
calls to see who could actually handle
the volume that we were going to need an
Apple stepped right up and said we will
make sure that we we get you what you
need in record time and they kept their
word and we also work with IBM that
helped us with the installation of the
Wi-Fi capability then we worked with
FedEx and UPS to develop a protocol of
how these would be shipped because
obviously if we're we were then under a
stay at home order and we're trying to
limit contact the last thing you want to
do is having people come out to have to
get their devices so all of those
partners were incredible and making sure
that they prioritize getting these
devices into the hands of students and
then what we'd also did is made sure
that we had a way of surveying our
students and our teachers to find those
individuals that maybe hadn't raised her
hand and said I need a device so that we
weren't leaving anything to chance and
as those devices started coming in again
they were prioritized for our most
vulnerable populations we went from
there and we expanded outward we still
have devices so that if you know in
there may be a case where a student had
their own device and now it's broken or
they can request one and we'll ship it
right to them
it was a massive undertaking but we have
some incredible colleagues here in the
Department of Education that just jumped
right into action one of the things that
we also did with these devices is that
we didn't want any family to feel that
they couldn't request a device because
what if it breaks am I responsible for
it you know I I'm not working what would
so what we did is every device comes
right out of the box that comes from
Wi-Fi enabled if they get a hard case
with it and we also purchased insurance
for every single device so our students
and parents don't have to worry worried
if something happens we want them to
have the device as well and you know
it's it's sometime in New York we
sometimes get a little blase about the
size of the numbers but you're right 290
thousand devices it says if you know you
took Seattle and you took I think in
Seattle Detroit San Francisco and Boston
and put them all together and we just
provided all of those systems with
devices that's kind of what the team was
able to do in pretty pretty rough good
time and how are y'all tackling and
that's amazing first of all and and how
are you tackling the the broadband issue
have the telecom carriers helped out
there yes our telecom providers have
been great they've really stepped up and
provided Wi-Fi access for our students
especially our students that live in
temporary housing or students that are
in our public housing units that was the
first place that they went in and made
sure that there was Wi-Fi available we
are in discussion with him now obviously
when we first went into remote learning
mode which was in March the plan was
that we would come back to face-to-face
learning in April
well obviously that that didn't happen
we were finishing the academic year
through June in remote learning summer
learning we'll be on in remote learning
mode as well and as I've mentioned our
goal is to be back person person
learning and in person learning
September but again
the medical medical experts are going to
are going to dictate how fast we come in
to in-person learning so I have the
entire organization focused on remote
learning through the rest of this
calendar year just to be prepared so the
we are in conversations now with all the
carriers about extending that Wi-Fi
access and looking at what that would
look like but I have to say that in
times of crisis you really see the true
nature of individuals and organizations
and I just cannot say enough about what
our
Wi-Fi providers have done about I've
mentioned some of the shipping companies
I've mentioned some of the technology
companies but a lot of partners that
have that provide online resources and
online materials have really stepped up
in a very unprecedented way to support
our children and and and I like to say
to them thank you because without their
assistance I know that we would not be
as successful with it as as I think we
are a lot of work to do we're definitely
building the plane as we fly the plane
but we could have done it without these
partners and businesses so I just want
to give them a big public shout out
thank you
no definitely yeah you know what are you
just described over the last one of the
best stories I've heard frankly in the
last couple of weeks and obviously I've
had a lot of conversations with folks
about the digital divide and device
access and that's really gives me hope
for where we can go and and to your
point not just through this crisis but
post crisis hopefully you know the
digital divide will be a smaller divide
or I'll hopefully even get solved
you know you touched on summer and
back-to-school how do you think summer
is going to be different this year you
know historically things like summer
programs would be for a subset of kids
maybe the kids who might have fallen
behind a bit do you think it's going to
be you know is it going to be hey
everyone needs to just keep learning
through the summer well I think one
thing I don't think we speak enough
about and it's critically important is
that the children and everyone in New
York City but everyone in the in the
world and in definitely in the United
States you know New York City was the
epicenter of the epicenter in the United
States which was New York State so we
were in the epicenter of the epicenter
we've been hit hard we we've lost
colleagues we everybody knows somebody
that has been lost or due to this
coronavirus maintain so we can't forget
the trauma that our students and our
staff and our community has undergone
it's a traumatic event and and we are
starting to see some of the signs of the
trauma you know with students and
students not being able to sleep so I
saw this also when I was superintendent
in Houston and we were hit by hurricane
Harvey and and I
remember seeing the manifestation of
trauma and how that affected people in
different ways the same thing is
happening with this so as much as I want
students to continue to learn and always
to be learning I also think that in the
first opportunity that we have for
students to just breathe that's going to
be good we've embedded social emotional
learning trauma-informed curricula and
trauma-informed supports in all of the
materials and all of the resources that
we've provided for teachers we also have
a parent hub where parents have all of
the not all of them but they have a lot
of resources that they can use to work
with their students their children and
help support their children as they work
through it and they can work through it
as well but I think that the
trauma-informed approach is going to be
critically important as we come back to
in-person learning as a result of that I
also think that summer we're gonna
prioritize our vulnerable students
obviously students with disabilities
will be prioritized over the summer
we've had a remote learning plans for
every one of our students with
disabilities that has adapted their
individual education plan for a remote
learning environment we also instituted
through a lot of feedback but we
instituted a new grading policy as you
can't you have new attendance policy as
well you can't shove the old attendance
policy into a remote learning
environment it just wouldn't work so we
have a new attendance policy we also
have a grading policy and in essence
students are continuing to work there
continue to turn in assignments but
instead of failing no students gonna get
a failure at the end of this academic
year what they'll get is a in progress
grade and what the in progress grade
signifies is that they have a little bit
more work to do to finish the
requirements of the class or finish the
requirements of the grade in the third
grade or fourth grade and then those
students will be prioritized for summer
learning in the remote learning
environment as well and the whole point
is to give students more time and even
there I would just say this the goal as
an educator for me has always been that
students master the the subject matter
that they get mastery
I'm not necessarily wanting students to
go for the a the B this year I want a
new master what they're trying to learn
so this has forced us now to really
embrace this notion of mastery learning
so the student hasn't mastered that
subject matter they're not gonna get a
failure they're gonna get in progress
and that says you have some more work to
do
we have some more work to do to support
you because the goal is that not that
you finished first but that you finish
and and and that again is changing the
narrative for how we look at and and how
we give weight to what grades really are
so anyway that's how we're prioritizing
fourth summer learning and I'll tell you
that many of the organizations and
institutions in New York City the
museums the Park and Rec Department the
libraries are really working with us to
be able to create even if it's some
virtual experiences that students can
have over the summer as well so it's not
just reading writing and arithmetic but
they also have some other exponential
experiences that they can engage in even
if it's in a virtual way over the summer
Wow and and just so you know you're
getting a lot of praise on social media
Peggy says Chancellor Carranza what a
great leader really getting this from
every angle it's rare to find people
with these abilities and I think every
can all sense the authenticity you know
we have a little bit of time left you
know what what do you see is the
scenarios for back-to-school obviously
there's the two extremes where a state
we stay fully remote or we go completely
back to normal but what are the other
scenarios that you're contemplating and
how do you think things might be changed
forever because of this well again we're
always going to be driven by what the
medical experts tell us so we're gonna
we're gonna listen to the science as a
parent I would not want my child to go
back to a school environment unless I
was confident that my child was going to
be safe secure and not infected so
there's a number of things that are
beyond our control as as educators and
my control as a Chancellor and so we're
going to listen to the medical experts
and make sure that we have the protocols
and the materials the testing that we
need and the the precaution the
precautionary gear that we'll need as
well
we've actually been modeling a number of
scenarios I'll just give you an example
of a couple and these are by no means do
I mean to say this is exactly what's
going to happen it's going to be driven
by whatever the circumstances are at the
time that the decision has to be made
about going back to in-person learning
or not but I'll give you an example so
when we come back it's pretty obvious
that we're gonna have to probably still
practice social distancing how do you
practice social distancing in the very
very tight-knit tight quarters that are
New York City's public schools
we're a very compact City so almost nine
million residents how do you do that in
our schools well so if you have an
elementary school for example does that
mean then that you have shifts so you
have an early morning shift and part of
your students comes in the early morning
and then you have an afternoon shift and
the other half the students come do that
too that that part of the learning and
then how do you split teacher schedules
to cover both shifts that could be one
thing or do you do something where it
becomes a little bit more of a remote
learning so for example you take that
same elementary school and you do a
cohort model so you have you take all of
the students you have cohort one two and
three cohort one goes to school
well cohorts two and three practice
remote learning on Monday on Tuesday
cohort two goes to school well cohorts
one and three are remote learning on
Wednesday cohort three goes to school
well one and two are practicing remote
learning that's only because you want to
provide the distance to do social
distance II what would that what will
that look like we know that the CDC has
talked about as part of what their
recommendations are is that students
don't congregate in lunch rooms when
whenever they get back to in-person
learning that they'll eat their lunch in
and their breakfast in the classroom so
what does that look like then and how do
you deliver it how do you serve it how
do you clean up after it what does the
day look like that what a buildings that
look like are their buildings that we
just are not going to be able to use
because they're just physically not
equipped to handle the social distancing
that may be required all
of those questions and a myriad of other
questions are things that right now
we're grappling with and modeling to see
how that would look like but it gives
you a little insight to the complexities
that all educators and all of my
colleagues that are systems leaders are
really grappling right now with because
and and we're doing it in environment
that we don't know what the ground floor
is gonna look like when we get to June
and July and August we so we just don't
know I'll give you one other example of
how the the ground is shifting right
beneath our our feet
two weeks ago nobody was talking about
PMIs which is a pediatric multi-system
syndrome which is occupants students
children are getting very very sick in
New York City we have over a hundred
students they're being treated for that
that's syndrome syndrome and and we know
that doctors are exploring is is there a
relationship between coded 19:00
exposure and then the this syndrome two
weeks ago we weren't even talking about
that so that's how rapidly this is
manifesting and iterating this virus is
iterating so the sand is definitely
shifting beneath our feet so what we're
trying to do is to model a number of
scenarios and be prepared so for what so
whatever those circumstances are we can
pivot very quickly to a model or at
least we've thought about what some of
these implications would be as we make
those decision to go back and do
in-person learning Wow well Chancellor
Carranza you know Kevin Hall of that
you've done I mean what it's heartening
as I said there's a lot of good news
embedded in obviously the larger
not-so-good context that we are all
dealing with especially that y'all are
dealing with in New York but I think you
know I speak for everyone watching that
you'll keep doing the amazing work that
you and your team are doing you know it
gives confidence and folks to see
leadership like what you're providing
and I'm honored frankly that you know
you're able to make a little bit of time
for us today because I can imagine
there's many many things going on in
your life world so thank you so much for
joining us and I hope we can do this and
again in a few weeks I would love to do
it and thank you for the invitation and
to everybody that's out there watching
listening stay safe
take care of each other this is a time
for us to take care of each other so
thank you for the opportunity in be safe
thank
you well thanks everyone for joining I
hope you were as inspired as I was you
know I think it's in times of stress and
times of crisis that you know people
show their show their true colors and I
think you know you're seeing examples of
really great leadership from Richard
from Chancellor Carranza and from many
others that we've had and and and it's
heartening to see how folks have been
stepping up to do the right thing look
forward to joining you on future live
streams I will see all of y'all tomorrow
stay safe and stay healthy just like
Chancellor krons has told us
you